Once my exploit needs a victim to navigate to my site and I already have like user interaction
required, I've already paid that cost. I can just like go crazy with it, like click here
five times, like drag this and drop it here. Stand up, do a dance, you know, like do the hooky.
Open up your webcam and give me permission. Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. I think- Record the pod with the victim.
Exactly. Record a pod with the victim.
Hey guys, real quick. I just wanted to tell you about our sponsor Threat Locker. Now, wait,
wait, before you hit the skip forward button, let me just say this. Most of the stuff that holds my
attention nowadays is Red Team stuff as well. But I sat down with the Threat Locker team this past week
to do a demo of their EDR software. And it was super technically fascinating how this thing works. So
check this out. You drop this thing on a system, right? And for the first week or so, it's creating
a policy and a profile for that system. It's logging all the executables, what child processes are being
spawned, the files and their hashes, that sort of thing. And it's creating this policy. Okay. Then after
the learning mode is up, we're in secured mode and that policy gets put into place. And anything that's
not on that allow list is immediately auto denied. That's the zero trust piece, right? So in addition to
that, they've got a bunch of crazy features like ring fencing and dynamic access controls that would stop a
malicious hacker at pretty much every step along the way. Actually, I was watching this demo and I was kind of
freaked out because I have no idea how I would cope with getting dropped into a Threat Locker system
as a Red Teamer. Anyway, if you want to learn more about this, head over to ThreatLocker.com
and request a demo. And when you do ask for my boy, Andrew, his demo was super to the point and he was
able to answer all my technical questions. All right, cool. Back to the show.
Alrighty, dude, we are recording. Matan Bear, welcome to the pod, man. It's been a long time coming.
Yeah, it's great being here. I'm super excited.
Yeah, me too, man. And so, man, this doc is looking super gorgeous. We were just, we actually,
you know, jumped into the studio here and we started chatting about all the stuff and then
we forgot to record. Yeah, I couldn't help myself.
So, we're going to have to... I was like recapping it before we even started. Yeah.
We're going to have to, we're going to have to go back and redo some of that conversation for the
listeners. But, okay. Whew, where to start? Let's start a little bit with the elephant in the room
here, Matan, which is the fact that you are 16 years old.
Yeah, the baby elephant in the room.
Exactly, the baby elephant in the room. Yeah.
And...
I am going to be 17 in like a few weeks, so I am getting old.
You are okay. Getting up there, getting up there. But you are competing at the live
hacking events. You've already been to like what? Three live hacking events?
Or four? Yeah. The AWC, which is like kind of a live hacking event. Yeah.
And then we had Miami and Singapore. Yeah. Yeah. And now...
And now this next one. All right, dude, that's amazing.
What a crazy career already at 16 years old. That's insane. Can you tell us a little bit about
how that came about? Because to be honest, most people at your age are just starting to,
you know, if they're lucky, they're starting to think, oh, maybe I would like hacking and then
starting their journey. Whereas you're already competing at the world stage level for this at 16.
So how did you originally get into this stuff? And what kind of path did you take to ingest all
of this so quickly? Yeah. So it's a great question. I'm naturally kind of, you know, curious. So...
I used to, and I still do watch like a lot of YouTube and the algorithm knows that I'm pretty,
you know, nerd sniper-able. So it kind of throws a lot of stuff at me trying to see if I can go down
some rabbit hole. And one day when I was like, I'm not sure when, but like, when I was like 14
or something like that, I was... Oh my gosh.
I threw like a Hacker 101 video at me or something like that. And then I tried to see like, tried to
started to watch like, NahamSec and Live Overflow and all of that, you know, classic channels. And
I set myself a goal of like, I want to find the bug by the end of the summer or something unrealistic
like that. And maybe it is realistic if you like getting into it and, you know, investing a lot of
time, but like for a kid, it's not really realistic. Right. Right. And then I, I like started to do some
labs and I think it was like still when I was 14 or maybe 15, I'm not sure. Like, I don't really have
great memory of the details. Your timeline is not developed yet. Yeah. That's hilarious. So when you say,
when you say labs, were you working on like the Portswigger labs or what kind of stuff?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The Portswigger labs on the web academy is still a great resource. The first thing I
recommend them. And actually I, I see a lot of people like, not a lot of people, but when I hear
Portswigger lab mentioned, it's usually, um, more like the XSS labs and the SQL injection labs or whatever,
but they actually have, um, a really good set of DOM XSS labs, which is what I specifically recommend.
And I haven't heard as much about that. So maybe it's a bit underrated. I'm not sure. Yeah.
Anyways, you don't, you don't hear about that too often, but they are pretty developed because they,
I know the team at Portswigger put a lot of time into the DOM invader. Yeah. They have like,
they have some great people on their team making those labs, definitely experts in their fields.
Yeah. So it's really worth it if you haven't checked out the DOM XSS labs specifically as a great,
like list of things and stuff. Um, so I was going through those labs, um, the SQL injection ones,
the more popular ones. And I was like looking at the site of Portswigger and I tried to put like,
um, a quote in the search field or whatever, and it threw an arrow. So I got excited. I thought I had,
like an SQL injection or something. Oh my God. And I submitted a bug, um, to actually to Portswigger
on HackerOne. And of course it was N8, but the person that triaged it was actually Albino Wax,
James Cattle. No way.
And he was like, it was super nice about it. He understood that I was like a beginner and he
actually recommended, like, I think you would love our XSS labs or whatever, like he gave me,
I don't know if it was like, um, something that he pasted in there, but it was super nice. Like,
instead of getting frustrated with it, like why am I getting spammed by like these trash reports,
putting quotes in search fields and calling it an SQL injection, but it was actually super nice
about it. And that sort of sent me down the XSS part and all of that. So.
Wow, dude, that's crazy. It's, it's insane to me how many origin stories sort of start from some
hacker, some, some more developed hacker, some, some pro hacker just being like kind and doing something
you know, out of, out of the ordinary for some random person. Right. I mean, that's the same
story with me is, is doggy G showed up to my like college, uh, cybersecurity club and, and, and then,
you know, here we are what seven, eight years, nine years later. And, uh, it's, you know, I'm just so
grateful. Um, so yeah, it's, it's definitely, that's something, uh, something that we need to be
paying forward in the community, I think is, is helping others that are early.
It can have, it can have a lot of impact on someone definitely.
And a lot of impact on a lot of programs apparently because, because here we are, um,
no, that's amazing, man. Um, okay. Wow. So a lot of that was, was originally those port swigger labs.
And then like, was that it? Then you just did the port swigger labs and then you were like full beast mode.
And then you just roll up and phone every programmer. I actually, I remember I had a really hard time,
like jumping from the labs that were like, you know, a single page or something. And you try to put an
HTML, an HTML injection in the comments and it works to like, uh, a full blown application where nothing
works basically. And you have to go through a lot of, um, different payloads and stuff. Uh,
I'm not sure how I got there eventually, like a lot of practice, I guess. I'm really not sure how,
how I managed to find the bug, but actually what I do remember is, uh, I submitted like some very
sheet bugs to Reddit, like some stuff that I would close as NA in like in the blink of an eye, but
they actually, they were super nice and they accepted it and they paid like some even as mediums
and stuff. Wow. Yeah. So that really like gave me the motivation and from there it was kind of steadier.
Yeah. Very cool, man. Yeah. I, I think you had an interesting point. Um, which is there,
there, there is this sort of disconnect between the labs and reality. And I think that disconnect is
largely in the area of how many times you have to fail and how many times you have to, you know,
how much time you have to spend just going from page to page and finding functionality that is interesting.
Yeah. And it's yeah, yeah, definitely. It's not just like how many times you have to spam a payload
for it to work. It's like, you don't have the same complexity and, um, you know, you don't have to
get intimate with the application. Exactly. Like you said. My man listens to the podcast.
That's great. Yeah. So you don't, you know, I've been listening to the podcast for a very long time,
like from that same place on the timeline, basically. Um, that's amazing. I've been the waxer. Yeah. Um,
but yeah, well that, that, that's great, man. And I, I appreciate you listening and, and I, I just kind
of want to say, like, I think that, um, I think there's a gap in that area that you said, you know,
with, with regards to having people having to search for a vulnerability inside of a lab system.
So I wonder, I wonder if there would be any ways to improve this with like, Hey, um,
you've got a, here's an application. There is a bug somewhere in this application. Go, go find it.
And when you do, this is the, you know, sequence to attack it. Like, I feel like those sort of labs
would be a little bit more impactful. Still, it would be, it would be definitely a step in the right
direction, but you can't make a lab that's as complex as like a real world target. It would
definitely be there's a hole there in the sort of ecosystem or whatever of, um, training for bug
bounty. That's there's definitely a need for something there. Yeah. Yeah. I agree. But I,
and I think that's, I mean, we preach it all the time on the pod, but like, I think getting out there
and failing is this, the, the, uh, you know, lab that you need in a lot of ways, but man, there,
that takes out a lot of smart people is, is getting out there and how much to how many times you have to
fail before you start seeing success. Yeah. But I mean, once you understand that,
once you understand that that isn't really failure because you can't logically expect for like more
than say 10% of, um, yeah, 1% to be honest. Yeah. Yeah. 1%. Yeah. You can't expect like a payload that you
put into work. Like, if you, if you just put a payload in and it works, you should get worried.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. For the program. Yeah. I wouldn't use the app if I were you. Yeah,
absolutely. And, and I think that's an interesting statistic to throw out there. I, it really is more
like the 1% number guys, uh, listeners out there. Like, like if you look at the amount of, uh, you know,
replay tabs I have and how many requests I've inspected and how much code I've read, you know,
1% or less of, of attack vectors are actually resulting in a bug. Um, so one of the first
things I told to one of my, the people I'm mentoring right now was, you know, go and look at 500 HTTP
requests and, and try to understand, write down what each one is doing. And, and after you get through
those 500 reps, you're going to be at a much better spot. Um, that's a great tip. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
all right. So that's a little bit about the history. So you started doing labs,
you started getting out there, you started failing until you got a couple nice little wins on, on Reddit.
Yeah. Though I will mention that this isn't like what I would recommend for a beginner to do now.
Um, there are some great, um, resources that you could like supplement, uh, the Portsweger labs with
because there is some stuff that's missing. Yeah. There's one, I don't really remember what it's
called, I think beyond XSS. It's a series by I think Huli, right? Beyond. Yeah. That is an amazing series.
I love that. Um, I love that list of, uh, write ups and I actually, I've used one of those pages in like
a few days ago on a real world target, a hardened reload target. So it's useful.
Yeah, absolutely. We shouted out that, that, um, that resource a couple of weeks ago on the pod.
And I, that was the first time I'd ever seen it like a couple of weeks ago. And I was like, this is
amazing. Um, and, and so definitely check that out if anybody is looking for, uh, additional information
on XSS stuff, because I think the fact that Matan Bear says, this is an amazing resource, uh, on client side
stuff should be more than enough for you to check that out.
Yeah. There's like, it's not only about XSS, though, of course, like that's kind of the point of the series.
It's beyond XSS.
There are some, yeah, there are some like, um, here you start to get into more like puzzly territory,
because with XSS, it's sort of the most straightforward of the client side bugs where you have like
JavaScript execution and then it's kind of game over.
Right. But you start to get into the more like gadgety stuff. Like I have a CSPT. What can I do with it?
Yeah. So it's a great introduction to that aspect of client side hacking, which is, I think the most
fun aspect and it's the most unique. You tend to get less dupes doing that sort of hacking.
Yeah, absolutely. So, so you said, you know, your, your favorite is client side stuff.
Why do you think that is? What is it about client side stuff that draws you, draws you to?
Yeah. I think it's just the flexibility there. The things you can do with client side hacking are
crazy. Like I get some chains sometimes with like, I sent you one a few days ago because I was so
excited about it or maybe a few weeks, but, um, with like 13 steps of what the attacker site does and
opening the windows and stuff and setting cookies and clearing them. And you can't do that same. You
can't play the same way with the application when you're looking at server side stuff. It's, it's way
more fun.
It is. There's a lot more capabilities. And I think, um, because of that, it's a lot more chainable,
but I think also the nature of it being, you know, white box that you have the source code that you can see
everything that's going on. I think that that does a lot more, more than I realized at the beginning
of my career, because, um, you know, when you look at some of these more complex exploits, uh,
I'm just thinking particularly of a couple of bugs that Shubs has, has shared with me.
Yeah. Yeah. I was gonna mention Shubs.
Yeah.
It's just like, you know, he can do the same thing on the server side.
And the, his own team in general.
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's stunning. And so I think, um, in situations like that, having white box,
having, having the code and being able to introspect into it is, is massive as well.
Um, but man, that chainable aspect of it is just, it's, it's so fun.
It's, it's so easy to debug and it's super interactive.
Yeah.
That's the aspect I love. It's like, you have the debugger and the UI all in the same place.
And you can like in real time input a line and see how we change the things. It's great.
It is. It is. And with that, actually, um, one of the top requested things for this episode was
talking about dev tools and general client side hacking tips. And I'm looking right now at two
sections that I have mega highlighted for the things that I am most excited about. And those two
sections, the whole section is just highlighted, um, which is great. So, um, talk to us a little
bit about, about dev tools and what kind of stuff you, you use in there that, uh, you think most
hackers should know about when, when approaching a client side target.
Yeah. So dev tools is definitely way more robust than you initially think it does have a few
limitations. Um, especially if you try to use it as an HTTP proxy, I wouldn't recommend that. Um,
talking from experience because sometimes I don't want to wait for bear up to load. Um, but it does have
some, um, some great features that, um, I'd recommend checking out. So if you're not entirely familiar
with dev tools, um, the first thing I'd recommend you to do is go into the settings. There's a little
gearbox there under the three dots or whatever, and it has a ton of different check boxes and stuff,
and you can enable like better features. And it's very, very useful. You have like a CSP violation,
stuff, a whole bunch of stuff that you don't see like out of the box. And once you're done,
like messing around with those settings and stuff, um, there are some tricks, like some very quick and
dirty tricks that I like to use while, um, testing with dev tools. So if I'm trying to
like modify some piece of code in order to test something or whatever, um,
I usually don't want to start, um, setting up a match and replace rule for it. And also don't want
to, um, use the override feature because, um, it tends to be a little hard and it messes up.
Yeah. That's been my experience as well.
Yeah. And it's like, it has a few issues because sometimes, um,
um, you know, the integrity attribute, um, yeah. So you can have on a script, you can have an integrity
attribute, um, that checks, the checks are more the harsh of the script. You could also have that
in like a CSP or something. And if you change it, like change the actual file with, um,
dev tools override, then it's gonna change the checksum of it and that will misbehave because
it's not gonna be valid anymore. So what I do is I set a breakpoint and with dev tools, there's,
there's actually a few different types of breakpoints, which is interesting.
There's the regular, like blue, um, breakpoint that will just break whenever, um, it gets executed.
But there's also, um, one that's orange, a conditional breakpoint, and you can put just like
a statement there or a piece of code, um, in the breakpoint when you sort of edit it and it will
execute that code. If that code returns true, then it's gonna break there. If it returns false,
it's not gonna break. So if I want to like override something for like a quick check or something,
I, I set like a break point there and I edit it and I just write out the code that I want to inject
there and I do like a semicolon and the right false at the end. So it doesn't use it as a breakpoint
and it's super quick. It's like, wow. What the heck? That's a genius technique. What the heck?
My thought. Why did you tell me about this before, dude?
Because I wanted to save your reaction for the part.
What?
We're farming content.
Dude, that is nuts. I thought, okay, so I was reading over this and I was like, oh yeah,
you know, conditional breakpoints, that's something that people need to know about. We should definitely
talk about that. Of course, I'm just using it like a normal human and just setting conditional
breakpoints.
Not like a crazy person.
Yeah. And you're like actually writing scripts inside conditional breakpoints. Wow. That's,
that's a super cool tip.
And you never have to leave like your environment and it's way like, it removes friction like you
talked about, I think maybe last week or something on the pod, um, about removing friction when you're
testing and it's super valuable for that.
Wow. Dude, that's nuts. That is so exciting actually, because you know, what I'm often doing
is I'm, um, I'm using match and replace, uh, to actually overwrite parts of the JavaScript. Right.
And, and so like what I'm thinking of a target that I, that I'm working on, um, right now. And I, I,
there's a JavaScript function that says like, oh, is this feature turned on? And I'm like, okay,
well, what if you just always returned to true, you know, like that would be really helpful.
Then every feature would be turned on instead of me having to like, you know, match and replace
this whole long list of feature flags. So I do that, but then you're absolutely right. You know,
sometimes there's integrity checks and that sort of thing.
For that specific use case, I would still use a match and replace because, um, the log points and
stuff, or the, I'm getting ahead of myself, the conditional breakpoints are only executed. Um,
if the dev tools is open, it's the same with, um, all the lights and stuff. So if you just want
to test the app, like the features and stuff, um, match and replace is the way to go. But if you're
looking at, uh, at the JavaScript and you want to quickly change some, something it's, it's way
quicker and way easier to do it with, by misusing a conditional.
Very cool. Very cool. But I think it's also important to shout out the, the conditional breakpoint,
um, actual functionality, which is that you can do a conditional breakpoint, right? You can write a
JavaScript statement, which will, if it evaluates to true, it will trigger. And if it doesn't,
then it will not trigger. So this is really helpful.
Yeah, definitely. What, what I sometimes do with it, um, when I'm trying to look at like
some message listener, um, I put like a breakpoint on the messages and sometimes, um, like usually,
you would get a ton of different messages from like browser extensions or from like the regular app and
stuff. So I just like, um, put a conditional breakpoint and I will do like E or whatever the
name of the event, uh, variable is not like ASDF or something. And then only if it has, um,
a truth, the, uh, ASDF what party it will break. So then in all of my testing, uh, messages and like
ASDF. And then you don't have to keep pressing that like little play button, play button, play button,
over and over again. That's great, man. Yeah. That definitely reduces friction and increases the
efficiency of your testing, which like, like we said before, I mean, it just has very, it has
cascading effects. You know, it continues. You think it's just a little small thing. I just got to
press, you know, play a couple of times here, but it allows your brain to, to not think about that
anymore.
Yeah. And even more importantly, um, you will feel less resistance before you do the accent. So if I'm like
trying to test something and I know that I'm gonna, um, have to press like forward 10 times,
I'm gonna be less likely to, um, to actually do it. So that's a great point. It's not only in the moment.
It's also, it also affects like the way you think about what you will do.
Yeah. So that's, that's a great point because it, it allows you to go further in your testing
because you're not getting tired as quickly. Like, oh, okay. You know, I've already tried three things.
I'm not gonna like go through this flow, you know, five more times. Uh, I'm just gonna skip it
versus if, if you just have lower friction, you still are able to just go, go, go. Um, so that,
that's, that's a great, we have a lot of different points to go through here. So we do, we gotta keep
moving. I'm sorry. What's the next one? Hit me. So I'm gonna go through the next one very quickly.
Um, we mentioned regular breakpoints and conditional breakpoints. There's also what's called log points.
So you put in some code there and it passes that code, like it's, um, a list of arguments to console.log.
So if you put like a string and then a comma and some variable, it will log, um, the string and the
variable and actually using commas in, uh, in console.log and stuff is very useful. And what I usually do with
this sort of, um, um, breakpoint, I have a very specific use case for it. Um, a lot of the time, the app, um,
the web app is gonna have some function. That's like a conditional log of something or something. So they will have
some like logging library, um, and they will check, like, sometimes they do it with, um, local storage
or whatever. They will check if debug mode is enabled. So instead of going in and like, um,
checking how they're checking whether debug is enabled and then overriding it or something,
I just set a log point in the function that logs stuff. Um, and that log point will just log the
arguments of the function. So if they have like a, a function called debug or whatever, that's
checking whether debug mode is enabled and if it is, it's gonna log something. My log point is just
gonna log it anyways. So then you get a bit more visibility into what's going on.
Dude, I did not know this existed. And let me tell you, so it might be a new feature because I didn't
know about it too until recently. Yeah. So, so I, I've like, I'm looking at this and what's
odd about this. So, so here's how you do this guys, um, in the dev tools, you know, they, they've
got the little line, line, you know, row or whatever on the left-hand side. I think it's called the
gutter technically, but, and you click over there and it sets a break point, right? Well, don't, don't
left click, right click instead. And you'll see, add log point. Here's what we can right click. Wait,
what are you, what have you been doing? Um, I've been clicking on it then clicking, um, on the side
panel, edit condition, and then you can change the, um, Oh, and then the log point is way more useful.
Oh, very interesting. So the reason I never knew that this existed is what I always do is I, I click
to add the break point, right? And then I right click on the break point to hit edit break point and then
set conditional break point. But actually if you right click after break points already set,
it won't show you the option for a log point. It'll only show you the option for break point.
So instead of left clicking the first time, don't you have a little drop down there? I do,
I do, but, um, up at the top. Yeah, I do have that, but I, I did, I never saw that before. So what,
what I'm going to do now though, is instead of right clicking, or left click, I'm going to right
click and hit add log point. And that will just add the log point on there. Wow. I did not even,
Yeah. It's hard to teach me stuff about dev tools because I kind of live there, but yeah,
I just learned a new trick. That's crazy, man. This is, this is, um, this is super helpful. So
we can just do, and then you said these, this input here is just essentially console.log at that
specific point in the code. Yeah. And it, it's not just console.log for a specific object. It like
passes a list of objects. So you can put like commas there or something. Oh, that's great.
Um, that is helpful. That is super helpful. Uh, and then, then I don't have to like, I don't have to
do the break point and then go to console and then type console.log. I can just log it.
That's super helpful, man. Wow. Um, very cool. All right. What else we got on here?
Yeah. Another one that is like very useful. Um, I've actually done this pretty recently.
Um, you can, um, sometimes it's very useful when, um, that opens a new window or a popup or something
to know what specifically it's doing, like what, um, arguments it's passing to window.open because,
um, there is some stuff you actually talked about. I don't remember when, but, um, if the name of the
window is guessable, there are some tricks you can do that. And if you're within the same tab
group as that window, you could like hijack it. Um, I haven't done it, but like,
dude, I've done it. I'll, I'll show you a report afterwards. It's, it feels so good, man. Like when
you, you know, the user clicks a button or whatever, and there's just no popup in it. And then it's like
in your other window in the iframe, it's just, uh, it's, I love it. Window hijacking is such a cool.
Oh, I, I see what you mean. So you make it like open because the best they're doing like window.open
and then passing like the target or the name, the name. Yeah. And if there's already such a window
in like an iframe on your page in the same tab group, it's going to open it there. Right. And then
you can, you control that is that iframe, right. So you can redirect the, the source of it. And if
it's like implicitly trusting that relationship with a post message, or if it's like,
what I thought you were doing was like, um, let it, letting it open it normally. And then
on your, um, tab running window, the top end with some attacker controlled URL, and then the name.
Yeah. That's also, but I'm going to let you finish up. No, no, no. That's also possible, but, um,
it's, it's better when they don't even see the popup, right. It just goes into your iframe and
then you can redirect it. And so, um, you know, one of the bugs that I've seen before is, uh, it'll
like the user will click a button for off and it'll like, uh, you know, you can hijack that, that window
and put it into your iframe, and then you can respond with your auth in there. And then maybe it'll
do some action with your auth code. Right. So then you can snag information that's now attached to your
account instead of attached to the victim's account. Oh, um, yeah, that's very cool.
It's, it's super fun. You're logging CSRFing them with, uh, yeah, that's fun. Um, and so that's,
that's a fun one. And then also sometimes they just trust the response and just, you know,
embed it into the page or whatever, or like give you access to some post message listener. Um, which
is really. It's definitely very fun when you start to get into those areas where the dev doesn't expect
any malicious input to be like, even in the equation. Yeah. Like they think that they already verified it
and all of that. So when you start having those, and sometimes like post message protocols or like
the communication can be very complicated. Like they're building a whole, um, protocol, uh, on top of
post messages and when the developer doesn't expect an attacker to be there, that can be like very fun to
exploit. Very, very impactful indeed. I wonder what you're talking about right, right now, Matan.
Yeah. Maybe you'll see a show and tell. Maybe you'll see a show and tell in a few weeks.
Sounds like a very sim, similar situation to one that I'm kind of familiar with right now.
So did you find one recently? Who knows? Who knows? We might be doing this show and tell together.
Yeah. I really hope we're not gonna dupe each other because I was actually, I mentioned it to
Nagli specifically. If someone is gonna dupe me on this, it's gonna be Justin.
I found the open reader. So, uh, you know, there's, there's some, there's some, uh,
well, we'll, we'll save that for the post post. My like, um, post message stuff is on the,
the other target. Oh, is it really? Oh, so we're not duping each other.
Okay. That's good. That's good. That's good. Yeah. Um, okay. Awesome. So, uh, essentially just to
TLDR this tip, cause we kind of got, got carried away here. Yeah. Yeah. Let's, let's move through
the other ones quickly. Um, uh, was, was that you're essentially, so what you've got in the doc here is
you're using, saying you're overriding window.open with a, a call to debugger, right?
Oh yeah. I forgot to actually mention what the trick was.
Yeah. Yeah. I got you though. I got you. So, and this is actually something that I think is really,
really interesting for people to know about, um, is, is you can trigger a debugger. Um, uh,
you can trigger a break point by using the, I don't know, is it a keyword debugger? It's, it's not a
function call, right? Yeah, it is. Yeah. Um, so that, that will trigger a break point if you just type
debugger, that's it. Um, which I think is really helpful. Yeah. And it's very useful because it will
trigger, um, if you have like a weird context where your code is running, like maybe on the CSDI
or something like that. Yeah. Yeah. Um, if you put like a, if you manage to make it run debugger,
then you can like look at that and see, understand the context way better. Yeah.
Mm. Very cool. Um, yeah, I think that debugger tip is, is really helpful. Um, I, I forgot to tell
you before this episode to get some water too, and I'm hearing you coughing, so get, get some water,
uh, while I, while I'm yapping for a second. Um, no, I, I have some, you have some good, good, good. Um,
yeah. So debugger tip, super helpful. I think that one's good. And we moved past this one that I'm
highlighting right now in the doc. And I want to, I want to go back to that. Talk to me about, about,
uh, on before unload breakpoints. So it's very similar to, um, to what we just talked about with
window.open. Um, if you're trying to like figure out, um, some, it does actually a few different
use cases for it. One is like, if, um, the app is moving very quickly, like if it's, if you're getting
redirected, um, a lot of times, like during an overflow or something like that, and you want to
understand like what's going on at, at every like stage of the way, um, you can set a breakpoint.
And the way it's actually done, it's a bit complicated. You go to, um, to the dev tools and
it's like in the sources panel, okay. You have, um, in the, uh, menu on the left, you have, um,
right above CSP violation breakpoints, you have event listener breakpoints, right. And you can go
there and you can expand the load category and you click on your check before unload. Yeah. Okay.
Before unload. And then once the page redirects itself, like with a setting location or something
like that, before that happens, it's gonna break point. It's gonna like break on dev tools. And then
you can see like, um, our daily directing what's happening like on the page and it slows down and
it's like, you can actually understand what's going on. Yeah. That's one of the worst things is like,
when you, you try to go to this page and it's got some weird functionality on it, but it just keeps
freaking redirecting away and you can't actually get dev dev tools to like open properly and do stuff.
So this will, um, this will be super helpful for that. And I, I, sometimes go ahead. Yeah.
Sometimes it's even more annoying. It has like a timeout of like five seconds or something.
Yeah. And then you try to like really quickly go through the, uh, code in like five seconds and
save it or something. Right. Have you, um, so I told a friend about this recently and he didn't know
and he was freaking out, but did you know that you can spam escape, uh, on a page that is redirecting
and it will cancel the redirect? Really? Oh, because it's like clicking the X on the, um, on the URL bar.
Oh, I don't know. I've never clicked the X on the URL bar. I just hit escape, escape, escape, escape,
escape, escape, and it's like, you're loading the page. You're like canceling the request.
Oh, um, Oh yeah. Yeah. It is like that. Okay. I'm clicking it right now. And it, yeah. Huh?
Very interesting. Yeah. That's nice. I haven't actually thought about using that. Yeah.
Yeah. So that, that helps sometimes when you're like stuck in the flow.
Oh wait, I, it's not, uh, related at all, but I just remembered some trick that I, um,
actually found. Hit me man. That's what we're talking about here. Hit me.
No, it's, it's not related to, um, DevTools at all. I, I have no idea how I just remembered it,
but it was actually a trick. I was, the origin story of the trick is, um,
I was helping someone download photos from Google drive to their phone. And the way I did it is like,
I, I click on download and then Safari on mobile has like a little pop-up and it asks you whether you
want to download the file or view it. Right. And I've seen that pop up many times,
but for some reason in that like moment, I stopped and I thought about it for a second.
And a common problem you have is if you can like upload a file or something,
no way. Are you kidding me? Can you do this with an SVG?
It's not as crazy. It's not as crazy as you might think, but if you can upload a file somewhere
and, but that file has like a content disposition header, if you try to make a user navigate to it,
to trigger like an XSS or something, it will not work. It will download it. Right.
And what I realized is like, if Safari asks you whether you want to view or download it,
will it ask you if you like have an HTML file or something? So apparently what happened is
Safari thought about that. Like the developers have thought about that scenario.
And for most content types, it will ask you whether you want to view it or download it,
but there's a blacklist of which ones, um, it doesn't allow you to click on view,
but there is one specific, um, content type that I did find. I don't remember which it is.
What do you mean you don't remember which it is?
I have it. I have it on my, um, on my chat with, I have it on my chat with the Joe and I sent it to
him and with you and I will check it. Go get that right now because I need that.
It doesn't trigger XSS. It doesn't trigger XSS. It will let you inject HTML, but for some reason
it doesn't run JavaScript. It's super weird. Oh, that sounds super.
But still that, that HTML injection is like, it will be in the, I think the URL bar will show
the vulnerable side. So you have impact out of it.
Dude, are you dropping, are you seriously dropping a Safari zero day on the pod right now?
What are you doing?
Maybe I don't know. I mean, there's plenty of Safari zero days to go around.
There's a, there's a blacklist.
We don't have to get cheap about those.
Oh man. The, the, um, the, so did you try the image slash SVG plus XML content type?
Did that one?
Yeah. Yeah. I tried a few. There's a, there's a list of, um, content types that let you, um,
XSS. I don't remember it's on some GitHub repo. It's a super useful list.
Yeah.
I used it on, um, on a Shopify bug once.
Oh, really? Oh, nice. That's great, man.
Yeah. I, I'm very interested to know what, um, the, the content type is for that.
Uh, so.
Yeah. I'm trying to find it.
Go, go, go, go.
So dig it up.
For leaving you hanging.
Yeah.
No, you're good. You're good. If we have to.
Oh yeah. It's, so it's interesting because I'm not sure. Yeah. It's text slash XSL, I think.
XSL. Oh, uh, the, so.
Is that the transformation language for, yeah, that's XSL.
Yeah, it is.
So you can, you can make the server respond with that. If you upload the next CSS file, I think.
Right.
Um, I'm not sure because I haven't actually tested it, but I think if you would upload them dot XSL file,
it would respond with that. And the, the most weird thing about the total functionality is if you don't
specify the content disposition header and you put an, an XSS payload in there, it will trigger and it
will XSS. But if you specify the content disposition header and then pick view, it won't run the JavaScript.
Really?
And it won't even let you in iframe stuff or anything.
But it will run some sort of sandbox HTML in there.
Yeah. It will let you like embed images and stuff. I haven't checked, I haven't checked forums,
which is interesting.
Forms would be interesting.
Iframes would be interesting.
Yeah.
Like objects.
Ice frames don't work.
Yeah.
Hmm.
But it's definitely like.
CSS.
Noteworthy.
Yeah.
CSS.
Not really interesting.
I don't know, but like you don't have anything to leak.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Maybe it would help you, um, fish someone though.
Maybe if it gets concatenated with a document, like, like maybe you have like a,
um, yeah, maybe there's.
Oh yeah.
Maybe if you have like an injection into yeah, but then you wouldn't be able to specify the extension
of that file.
Ah, that's true.
Yeah.
That's true.
But I wonder if, um, if, uh, password managers would auto fill it.
I wonder if it's like considered same origin, that would be a sick.
A.
Password manager.
I mean, it's a.
And then you leak it with CSS injection.
Oh my gosh.
Or a form of CSS injection.
Yeah.
That would be crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
So we just took like on live, we just took a back class.
That's like completely ignored.
Nobody talks about it.
Oh man.
And yeah.
Yeah.
That's great.
I mean, the funny thing is, um, Johan, it was like, he found a bug like this and usually
you like auto ignore it.
But for some reason he asked me like, do you have any crazy trick for it?
And I was like, I was downloading, uh, images one day.
As you do, as you do.
Yeah.
As every big story starts.
Oh, so I, I don't know.
I don't know why I didn't add that to the doc, but I'm glad I remembered.
Me too.
Okay, dude, we are only four, four bullets in.
We got to move.
Okay.
What's this next one?
How much time?
Um, I have a hard stop in an hour, an hour 30.
So I think we don't have any time.
Yeah.
I think, I think we're good.
Uh, but yeah, let's, let's, let's keep moving.
Um, what is this next one here?
Um, this is a good one.
Yeah.
So yeah, it's just, um, it's a section of the, um, that to the side panel that you have
to know.
I use it all the time.
Mm-hmm .
It's the call stack section.
So if you know VS code, it has this very useful feature where if you like, um, control click
on something and you jump somewhere, you can use, um, alt and the arrows or, um, like you
go forward and backwards in history on, um, on the browser, you can use it to go, um, back
to where you jumped from.
Mm-hmm .
But on, in the dev tools, which is actually a feature that I really miss, um, you can't
do that.
So you tend to get lost if you like, um, you reading some, uh, part of the code and you
have a break point somewhere and it triggers and you like, try to look for a string somewhere
and you start to jump around the code to different sections.
It's very easy to get lost.
Yeah.
So if you just expand the call stack section and you click on the uppermost, uh,
in the uppermost entry, it will just jump to where your current break point is.
Yeah.
That is super helpful.
I use that all the time.
And actually while you were saying it, I was thinking, man, I think there was a way to jump back and forth
in, in dev tools.
I would love to know that.
Yeah.
It's I'm looking at it right now.
I found it at one point.
I thought, where, where was it?
There's so much obscure functionality.
There is.
I'm looking, I'm scrolling through the, um, through the shortcuts tab right now.
I, I can't, I can't find it right now, but I want to see that there actually.
Is there a shortcuts tab?
Yeah, there is.
Yeah.
So if you go to, if you go to, um, the settings, the little, and then all the way down at the bottom,
uh, on the left-hand side, there's like preferences, workspace experiments, whatever, and then shortcuts.
So I think there's some stuff in there, um, that allows you to navigate through,
but I can't figure out which one it is now.
So we'll have to, we'll have to go back to that afterwards and see if we can.
Oh yeah, there it is right there.
It's, uh, I think control, uh, that might not be it.
Control like open square bracket and control closed square bracket.
But we'll, we'll, we'll go back and we'll figure that out afterwards.
But I'm pretty sure there is a way to do that.
And if there's not, oh yeah, someone needs to do that.
So it says jump to next editing location and jump to previous editing location.
What is, what is it?
It's alt, alt minus and alt plus.
That's right.
Alt minus alt plus.
I'm not sure if plus means holding shift, but yeah.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Let me see if it at editing location now, I'm not really editing things.
Yeah.
It does work.
Wow.
Yeah.
It does.
Check that out.
Super useful.
Man.
I, I hope you would have told me that earlier.
Yeah.
These, these sort of things are super nice and, and allow you to feel a lot more comfortable
in your tools.
Yeah.
Maybe if you can rebind it, I can maybe just use the VS code rebinds.
I think, I think that'll be really good.
Um, while, while you were talking about all of these things, I wanted to shout out one more,
um, break point.
That's kind of interesting, uh, which is the XHR and fetch break points.
Have you seen those before?
No.
Um, I mean, I've seen that it exists.
I haven't, um, looked into it.
This is, this is helpful when you're trying to figure out what piece of JS code originated
a request, you can set that break point.
Um, and it essentially, it's in that same panel on the right hand side.
Oh.
There's an easier way to do that though.
The initiators.
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah.
Network tab.
I think that is, I think that is helpful and it's very nice to see the call stack when,
um, you have like a specific initiator, uh, for a specific request or whatever.
I think the break point is also really helpful because then you get to jump back and forth
between that call stack, uh, like you were just mentioning and you can go through.
Yeah.
I've definitely had times where I like went to the initiators and then set a break point.
So this is just an easier way to do it.
Yeah, exactly.
Just like that.
Um, but that initiator's thing is really helpful.
We have to move on though.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
One, one, one more thing, uh, before I, I bulldoze your podcast, uh, Matan, I wanted
to, um, I wanted to shout out a technique that you actually taught me, um, which was that I
didn't know that you could go to the application tab in dev tools and click on frames down at the
very bottom.
And it'll show you the various frames that you have.
And on that, and the CSP on that page, there's the CSP, which is super helpful.
And you don't have to like, you don't have to like copy it into CSP evaluate or anything.
It's just like they're highlighted, broken out, nice and easy to read.
Yeah.
I forgot to mention it is good that you remember that.
Yeah, no, that's, that's, that's really good.
Um, so should we move on to this section?
Yes, let's do it.
Okay.
So dev tools and general testing tricks done.
Now we've got general client side hacking tips hit us with the goodness, Matan.
Yeah.
So these are just like some very general tips.
I usually don't, uh, like, um, very general tips because they can feel less actionable, but with my
sort of style of hacking, it's very, what I do is very target specific.
So kind of the only tips I can give are pretty general, um, except for like tricks and shout out,
like, like we just did with them with the content type, uh, little piece there.
But, um, some of these tips are more applicable to beginners and some just like general good tips.
So what I would recommend is, and this is a pitfall that is for people that are kind of newer to, um,
to client side hacking.
I think that this would be a pretty common pitfall.
Don't just like dive into the JS.
You have minify JavaScript for a big application can be so huge.
Super intimidating.
It's so, yeah, it's super overwhelming and you can't, maybe some people can do it, but you can't
just start reading it and actually understand what it does.
What you can do, and this is way more productive and you, it's a way to only read the code that is
interesting.
What you have to do is utilize as much dynamic analysis as you can.
So this means like whether it's installing Domlogger, which is, um, a way to do, um,
dynamic analysis or using breakpoints or, um, like all of the, I think all of the, um,
most of the tips we just gave are like applicable to dynamic analysis.
Like if you, if there's, um, a window.open and you're trying to understand that functionality,
instead of trying to read the whole JS code, like you would with the source code or something
and trying to figure out where they're opening that window, set a breakpoint on window.open
or something like that.
So utilize as much dynamic analysis as you can.
And also, um, you have to get to know the application.
A lot of client side hacking is just talking.
What did you say?
Matan?
You have to get intimate with the application.
That's right.
That's correct.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
A lot of client side hacking is just hacking.
And I think for me, it's like, maybe a lot of my time is spent looking at the JS code,
but a lot of it is just like spent looking through menus, trying to see which functionality seems like,
um, interesting to me out of instinct or something like that.
So don't just like dive into the JS and try to find like sources and things and all of that.
Um, just from reading the JS or yeah, try to get to know the application.
And it also, what it allows you to do if you actually know the application well,
you need to have less, you can have less powerful primitives, um, and keep the same impact.
So what I'm trying to say is say you have some application and you've studied the overflow of
it very well.
And you know that you can somehow get the code to land on any page in a specific domain.
Right now, if you find an excess, an excess in the domain, that's great.
Like you have, um, 80 on stuff, but now you can have with the less powerful primitive,
like leaking the, um, refer or the location or whatever, you could achieve the same impact.
And now by just no getting to know the application and looking into that flow, which is, there was no
reading JavaScript involved in that.
You just saved yourself a lot of time and you made your life way easier.
Yeah.
And your eyes aren't bleeding because you've been staring at minified JavaScript for hours.
There is one hacker that I know that just reads JavaScript like a book.
Uh, and I just like the most insane thing I've ever seen in my life.
But I really, I really liked that tip.
I'm going to, I'm going to wrap that up for the listeners.
Taking dynamic analysis and using that to inform your static analysis, right?
Like to understanding what pieces of code are running via, via dynamic analysis, and then going
back and looking at the surrounding code in the call stack and, and that sort of thing can really
help you understand, help you narrow down what pieces of code are interesting and what is just the
endless fluff that gets thrown into all of these like web packed monstrosities that we have nowadays.
Um, that's, that's really key.
I think I'm way more, um, lenient towards dynamic analysis than you might expect.
Like 99% of my time reading JavaScript is us like looking into setting breakpoints, looking at the
values of the different, um, variables and all of that, just like pure dynamic.
Yeah.
Um, you mentioned DomLogger++.
We just recently did a masterclass on DomLogger++ in the critical thinking, uh, critical thinkers
exclusive tier on discord.
Um, you've been using that for a little while.
Yeah.
I watched the recording.
I've watched the recording of that masterclass because I couldn't make it to the, um,
to the actual, uh, class, but it was great.
Yeah.
It's very useful.
So, so how are you using that tool and what kind of sources and syncs are you, are you
detecting on?
Yeah.
So I'm actually, I'm not using it to the full potential.
I haven't seen either.
Like, yeah, I'm, I have been using, um, I haven't known about all of the different stuff
you can do with it with like, especially events and stuff.
There's some very interesting stuff you can do those around surrounding events.
Um, but what I've been using it for is just like query parameters.
Um, for analysis of messages and stuff, I use, um, post message logger and for analysis of like,
which, um, which URL parameters or, um, hash parameters I can use.
Um, I use, um, dom logger and that kind of covers like all of your, um,
um, like globally applicable, uh, sources.
Mm.
So are you hooking like that?
Yeah.
Like what are you doing for, for hash related stuff?
Are you, are you hooking anything for that?
So hash related stuff.
I, I do the exact same thing I do for search.
I just hook, um, URL search parameters dot prototype dot get and dot has.
Um, so.
It catches like, I want to say most of the cases, definitely not all, which is why I want to improve
that, um, config with like to catch, uh, cases where parameters are being, um, passed with regexes
or with splits and stuff like that.
Yeah.
And what I actually want to do is catch cases when there's a sling that gets a split on.
And.
Ampersand dude, I was literally just about to say that, that, that is like, I, I haven't seen anyone do that.
I think that should be pretty doable.
Right.
Cause if we can just, with dom logger, we can override that function, right?
Dom logger plus, plus we can override that function.
If it's got the ampersand character return something that we can get a little bit more introspection into.
Yeah.
And then essentially log all of the parameters that are, that are being parsed out of any string that contains the ampersand.
And it will be like pretty high signal.
Um, which is like a problem that I had with, um, other conflicts that I've tried.
Um, is that there's a lot of the code running on a page and it can get very noisy if you hook too much stuff.
Yeah, it can.
But I mean, which strings get split on ampersand sub urban parameters.
Exactly.
It's pretty much just that.
And it, I think there also needs to, I need to do some analysis of JS files to understand like what the common flow is, because they might be like trying to detect the question mark or something like that, or trying to test, detect the hashtag before they do the split.
Um, so maybe we need to hook that too, to just check and see what potential stuff there could have been.
Yeah.
In my experience also, um, the weirdest parsing behaviors are those of all, all their functionality.
Mm-hmm .
And that's definitely functionality that you don't want to miss.
Yeah.
So it's, it's gonna be valuable to try to catch those as best as you can.
And, and did you see in the masterclass, there's a, um, there's a way that he has, has it set up where it can like pop up a little alert box when something happens.
So what I'm thinking about doing is I've just got a long flight coming up here.
So I'm going to try to do this on the flight is building a Dom logger plus plus config where it will.
essentially just pop up on the screen, any, any calls to, uh, uh, URL search params dot prototype dot get dot has, or any of those splits.
Right.
So any page I navigate to, it just automatically says, Hey, these are all the possible query parameters for this page that are being parsed by the client side.
Wouldn't that just like, oh, that would be amazing.
I think alerts would be a bit too spammy.
Mm.
I, I do it with like, um, a number, like that says how many it found, like, uh, sort of like with, um, with post message logger.
And then I check the, um, dev tools to see which they found.
Nice.
So we definitely should get through this way faster.
Oh my gosh, dude.
We're spending a ton of time on each one.
Dang it.
We're going to have to come back and do another episode.
I don't think we're going to get to the, um, to the extension hacking stuff.
I don't think so either.
We're going to, we'll do another one.
Maybe we can record one live in Vegas.
That would be fun.
Oh yeah.
That would be very fun.
Yeah.
So, um, let's move on, uh, in this section.
Let's do it.
Um, oh, this was, this was a great one.
Okay.
So this is, this is, this is exactly what I'm talking about when it comes to chaining stuff,
right?
Like, uh, trying to weave your way into these like situations where you have these super,
um, mangled payloads and you've got to get it past a laugh and there's a bunch of tricks.
So drop these, drop these tricks on the listeners.
This is great.
This one is very fresh in my mind because I've exploited it on one of the, um, programs,
which I really like.
Mm.
Um, I'd like used it in the next part, uh, in many situations, um, when you're trying
to like escalate an XSS or maybe to exploit an XSS, um, you have to get like, at the end
of the day, you have to get the app to execute like a big script.
Right.
So the way I do it is I just on my server host, like a big script that I can write, like,
um, with an idea or something easily.
And then you have to get that up to execute that big, uh, script.
So it's kind of a big step to go from alert origin or something like that to executing that
huge script.
And the easiest way that, um, works like 90% of the time to do that is using the import function.
It's not really a function.
It's a keyword, but you can just treat it as a function.
JavaScript has, um, uh, a function that just basically it's just, um, XSS as a service.
Yeah.
I love it.
Just like, yeah, you call import, you put in like your URL or something.
Inside of that, uh, import statement in, uh, with quotes, like with a string.
And it just fetches that, um, that file and just executes it.
So you've gone from like a fetch dot text, dot something and evil in it, just like a single line,
which is very useful.
Um, so what I usually do in like 90% of the cases, I like find an XSS with alert origin.
Then I change it to do like import and then the path to my file.
And then I have like a nice way of editing the JS file in an ID and having the page execute it.
Um, but there are some cases where this won't work.
Number one is like when you are dealing with a WAF or maybe with an input that, uh, is limited in characters or maybe in character set.
Um, uh, in those cases, um, uh, maybe the import won't work because either the waffle block it or maybe, um,
um, brackets are, uh,
I want to say there's some weird context as well where import just doesn't work.
Like it, like, yeah.
So yeah.
What is that?
Do you know about that?
Do you mean like with the CSP?
No, no, it's like, like I've gotten a weird error when I'm trying to execute import from like
within a.
A module.
That isn't a mod.
Yeah.
Like a module or something like that.
And I haven't fully assessed what that means, but like 95% of the time it works for me.
There are two types of imports.
One is like an import where you just write import and then a space.
And that only works for modules.
Yeah.
And that import statement is very useful because that import statement automatically gets hoisted to the top of the file.
Mm.
So when you could get your script to execute before any other script in that file, if it's in the context of like
an injection into a script or something like that, but the import statement that I'm talking about is the more like a generally applicable one.
Um, I think it's called the dynamic import or something like that, where you just treat import as a function.
So just call it with brackets.
And I think that should work in.
I I've been using import with, with as a function call, um, you know, for a couple of years now.
And there are some scenarios for some reason where it will work.
So maybe I'll.
I haven't encountered it, but maybe it's just because it's niche.
Yeah.
It could be niche or there could be some like script.
Delegation type delegations or something like that, where it doesn't work because it is, you know, for this sort of modularized environments.
But, um, yeah, I mean that, that.
Yeah.
Function is like absolutely pivotal to, to getting arbitrary, uh, JavaScript execution in most scenarios.
So in the cases where it doesn't work, like say a CSP or, um, a laugh or something, what you have to do is you have to think about like how you manage to get a script to run in the first place.
Mm.
So for example, recently I had, um, such a good, on some target.
This is such a good.
I had, uh, an XSS, um, and they had, I had like an HTML injection and they had, um, uh, CSP.
And the CSP had like, um, in the script source is the loud data URIs.
So I inject my script.
I inject like script source data, and then I put my script there.
But then I was trying to think, and I was also, if that's not enough, I was also like limited in characters.
Oh my gosh.
Um, which I love those scenarios.
Yeah.
You gotta code off it.
There's one, yeah.
There's one really good one on my blog.
Um, Oh my gosh.
The four character.
Yeah.
Is that what you're talking about?
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
Anyways, um, I was like limited in character in both in character set and in payload length length.
So, um, that was kind of tricky, but, uh, what I, I sort of tried to think like, okay,
how can I make arbitrary JavaScript under?
So the first payload I was kind of thinking about was maybe, um, creating a script element.
So script or maybe S equals a document create element script, and then assigning a source to it,
and then, um, uh, injecting it into the page.
But that was too long.
And I tried to think about it.
And then I eventually realized that what my primitive was, was basically just an HTML injection.
Right.
Mm.
So what I could do is just like reintroduce that primitive or like re exploit it somehow.
So what I eventually did was just like get, um, uh, some variable that has like malicious,
that can have malicious content.
I'm going to go through the list of like these sources in a second.
So I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh, I, uh,
same, uh, vulnerability that I had a second ago, but now I'm not limited, um, in character set or in character length or anything.
So when you're trying to get those, um, those exploits to work, it's really important to think, like, how you manage to get it in the first place.
So for example, um, if you maybe got it through a JavaScript URI, then you can do like open and then put the JavaScript URI in there.
Like you should think on a low level, like how you manage to get XSS to work there.
And in terms of like the sources for where you could get malicious input from, there are a few options.
Like I mentioned, you can use the name of the current window and the way you set it from an, as an attacker, you either, um, in your malicious site, you either change the window.name and then redirect the window.
And the window.name will stay constant after the redirect.
Or you can, um, open the vulnerable page and in the window.open call the second argument, you can put a payload there and it will be, um, its window name.
That's something else I want to hook in DomLiber++ by the way, is any window.open that has a name, uh, property attached to it.
That's great.
That's a great, um, idea for a config.
Um, but anyways, what I did there was, um, in that case, I couldn't, um, get the window.name to be a malicious value.
Um, I won't get into the details, but.
Come on, Matan, give us the details.
Um, so, um, the chain was very complicated.
I had like a self XSS, right.
And that self XSS was the one that I said was limited in, uh, characters and stuff.
Right.
And that self XSS, I was trying to get it to trigger on, um, on the victims account.
So.
I have no idea how I'm gonna, um, put it into like a podcast.
Welcome to my world, dude.
It is so hard.
Like you, I, I'm a year and a half into this more even in, into doing, running this podcast.
And I still have such a hard time taking these complex convoluted chains and exploits in like, just talking through them.
Even though it's like what I live and breathe every single day.
Yeah.
Um, I'm gonna try it though, because it's very interesting.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me, let me, let me go get my chair.
Hey guys, real quick.
I just wanted to give a shout to the hacker content team.
They have been absolutely killing it the past couple months, taking the content from the podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media posts, whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever.
They've been rocking it.
So, uh, I just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts of cybersecurity content as well as social media management.
They do technical blogs.
They do, uh, comprehensive social media management.
Uh, so if your organization could benefit from any of those types of services, make sure you head over to hacker content.com, drop them a line and mention the podcast when you do to get your first month of cybersecurity content marketing services for free.
All right, that's it.
Let's get back to the pod.
All right.
So, all right, we're back.
Let me get some water.
Story time with Matan here.
I'm excited.
So yeah, give it a shot, man.
It is hard to put some of these things into words, but.
I'm going to open the list of steps I sent you.
Okay.
Um, about that specific bug.
Well, you know, which one I'm talking about.
I do know the one you're talking about.
I I'll mention this though.
Here, here is what he, the tip that he had in the doc on this while you're pulling that up, Matan.
Yeah.
He's listing here a bunch of ways to, to, to smuggle in your, your payloads into this, into this access environment.
You got, you got window.name.
You've got opener.name.
That opener.opener.name, right?
There's a chain of all these things you can do.
I'm actually going to go through them real quick.
Okay.
So we don't have to like come back from a tangent.
Yeah.
Um, so each one of those, um, of those different.
Um, ways to smuggle input has like its pros and cons.
So the classic one is like name, which is a super, super short payload, like four characters.
Yeah.
And, um, the window.name has basically no length limit and you can put any character in there.
Um, but it does require you to form an attack, to have like an attacker's page.
The victim has to navigate to an attacker's page.
You can't like put, uh, the URL of the, um, vulnerable page directly and have the victim navigate to that.
So that's, um, the con that, that specific way has.
And you could also, if you need more, um, inputs, you could do opener.name and opener.opener.name, which the attacker would have control over.
And the other one, which I listed there, there are a few, um, you have, you can add with a very short payload, a message listener to the page that you have code execution in.
So you can just write on message equals, and then, um, some, uh, variable name like E and then do an arrow.
So like an equals greater than, and then the code that you put there will have access to like an E variable.
Um, that the data of which has like malicious input.
There is that two cons to that, um, payload while it doesn't have a length limit or character, uh, limit, a chance limit to the input you can inject.
It does require you to have a greater sign symbol.
And, um, you need to have an attacker's page to exploit it.
And the other one, um, which is useful, um, is location.
So if you have control over the location, which you do in most cases, um, you can just use location.
You don't even have to use like location dot hash or anything, just location because it contains the hash, obviously.
Um, and that will not have a length limit because the hash of the URL has absolutely no length limit.
You can put as much, as much stuff there as you want.
Wow. That's crazy.
Um, but it does have a chance at limit.
Um, if you've ever like me try to exploit, um, some piece of code that does like document dot write, um, location dot hrl.
You'll know that the browser automatically encodes.
So annoying.
Absolutely infuriating.
Any like greater sign symbols, it encodes it.
So if you want to use the location as a source of malicious input, you'll have to pass it into document, into decode URI component.
If you want no child set, um, limitation, or you could use an escape, which is a deprecated function that does basically the same thing.
Really? It's shorter.
And it's way shorter.
Yeah.
That's what I ended up using on, um, the exploit, which we're going to talk about in a second.
Um, and the last one, which is like a lengthy payload.
Um, I'm not sure in which cases you'd use it though.
I did, um, in one case, talk to someone which had to use that specific payload because all of the other stuff, um, didn't work for him.
You can, um, fetch an attacker controlled, um, script or something.
And then, um, you have to either await that fetch or do a dot then.
And then you have to get the text from that, um, request.
And then you have to do a dot then on the text call because it reads it asynchronously.
And then you're going to have malicious input.
Um, I'm not sure in which cases you have to use it, but it definitely does exist.
Um, in cases where you have to use that specifically.
So let's get into our story time.
Let's, let's do that.
I want to add one more thing about this fetch thing.
I actually did end up using a payload very similar to this the other day.
And the situation was that the CSP had a script source on it.
Um, that included, uh, unsafe eval or whatever.
Uh, so I was able to get XSS.
But, uh, it, it did not allow me to import scripts from other domains.
Um, and, but it didn't have a default source, uh, or a connect source or anything like that.
So I was able to just like do a fetch and then get the response and then eval it.
In that case, you could have, um, used the evil name or something like that.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That also would have done it and that would have been much shorter.
But, uh, sometimes you just don't need it to be short.
Right.
And using fetch or something like that, it is well more, um, comfortable and easier because
you can just like edit the script that you're hosting on your page.
It's, it's easier to read too for the devs.
Yeah.
Um, all right, dude, let let's, let's do story time now.
Uh, what, uh, what, what bugs you got to, got to share with us.
Yeah.
That, that exploit was definitely not easy to read.
Actually the, the triage team specifically mentioned that it took them a while to figure out what
I was doing, which is super funny.
That is funny.
And also I think that report got like NMI that at least like five times in my H1 triage.
Yeah.
Um, but I had, um, self XSS, um, that had a chance at limit though most characters were
allowed and a length limit.
And what I was trying to do was both get it to evil, like a big script.
Like we just talked about, like we just talked about and get it to trigger on a victim's page
on the victims like session, whatever.
So the way I ended up doing it was very complicated, but we're gonna go through like the thought process.
So I had the HTML injection walking on my account.
So the first step to have the victim.
See that page is to have them log into my account.
So that's like a must have.
Um, so what ended up using on that specific target, they had SSO functionality, which is awesome.
You love to see it.
Yeah.
It's very interesting.
Not only from like a client side hacking perspective, just generally, there are a lot of different, um, attack scenarios with that.
And, um, you can use it just like as a CSRF login CSRF by design.
Like I've used that on a few targets and just like using this as always an open as an login CSRF.
And you could also use it in some cases as an open redirect.
But anyways, I, so the first step of the attack was to use the SSO to log in the victim to your account.
And then you redirect them to the page where we have XSS and that the access would trigger.
Um, which is already great, but, um, we don't like have access to their session because it triggers on the attacker session.
And usually what you would do in this case in those sorts of situations.
And I think you talked about it on your episode with, um, Yusuf Samuda, which is a great hacker.
Amazing.
Um, yeah.
Yeah.
But what you usually do is like you open a window to the vulnerable site, um, before you log them out and then you do the whole attack.
You open, um, you log them out of their account into your account.
Then you access it and everything.
And then once you have a code execution in the vulnerable origin, you take over the page that you opened in advance and you leak sensitive stuff from it, like access tokens, et cetera.
Right.
That does have some limitations though.
In this case, what I was trying to do, the XSS was in a sub domain and I didn't have any, uh, super sensitive data in the sub domain.
It didn't have sensitive data, but I didn't have a way to impact integrity from that sub domain.
And the only thing I had was like, it had a cause policy that trusted that sub domain.
So if the XSS were to run in the victim session, I could use it to like, send fetch requests to sensitive APIs and stuff.
And as the victim in the session.
So I had to make it execute in the victim session.
Like I couldn't use any weird trick of like on the attacker session, but you have a window and stuff.
I had to have it actually in the victim session, which was to get a bit more creative.
Yeah.
And I'm actually very glad that that happened because the trick which I ended up using was kind of like pretty globally applicable.
There was, there wasn't a ton of the like targets.
Tell it to me then Matan, come on.
Yeah, I'm getting that.
Okay.
So what I did once the victim is logged into the attacker's account.
The first thing I did was, um, wipe all of the cookies using a cookie jar overflow.
Um, which by the way, I was trying to use your, um, your little page that, um, counts how many cookies you have.
Yeah.
And it doesn't work on Firefox.
It's completely like, um, loops indefinitely.
Are you kidding me?
Anyways.
Um, and I was checking it on Firefox because the triage was using Firefox or something.
Anyways, um, once I wiped the cookies, the victim is now logged out of, um, of all of the accounts.
But I still have a JS execution because it's still running the script that I have provided.
Um, so now, um, the situation that we have is like, we have a JavaScript execution in a software.
Um, and the victim is logged out of all of the accounts.
So then what I did before all of the attack is the attacker.
I would, um, take the note of the session token value that I have.
And then, uh, during the attack, after I logged the victim out of, uh, all of the accounts, I then set the cookie and set it with like a specific path.
So it takes precedence, precedent, precedence, I don't know.
Um, so it takes precedence and, um, I provide, uh, I fixate like the session to the session that I, uh, have taken in advance.
How do you have access to the session token?
Is that, is it HTTP?
Yeah, so.
Is it HTTP?
It's not an HTTP only variable?
Or a cookie?
No, it's like, eh, it is, but I, what I did is I cleared all of the cookies.
Right.
And then I just put my own cookie that isn't like HTTP only.
The server doesn't know it's not HTTP only.
It looks the same to him, to them.
Right.
And what I did is I, I take that session, the attacker session, and I put it on the like specific path of the vulnerable page.
And I fixated on the victim's browser.
So now what happens is every time the victim navigates to that specific page, the session that the service, that the server is actually gonna pay attention to is gonna be the attacker session.
So now it doesn't matter what's actually going on in the browser though.
For that specific endpoint, the victim is logged into my account.
So now the next step was to make sure that the victim was logged into their account for every other endpoint.
And this is where it gets actually pretty crazy.
I made sure that the exploit can work only with like, with a malicious, like the payload in the location.
So I didn't have to make them navigate to an attacker's page or anything just in the location, which is why I had to investigate like all of the different ways to get malicious input.
Right.
And then once I got it to work only with location information, what I did once the session was fixated on everything, I found the session, I found the cookie on the application that once, every time the victim logs into the account,
the server checks that cookie and uses it to figure out where the victim should be redirected.
Oh, it was actually happening on the client.
But anyways, that was like the idea.
This is insane.
The functionality, the functionality there was like, if you try to navigate to some page, but you're unauthenticated.
So it redirects you, saves it in the cookie.
And then once you log in, it redirects you back.
So what I, how I abused this cookie, it didn't allow any origin, but it allowed like origins of the, it allowed like redirection to, to pages of the application.
Didn't allow me to redirect to an attacker's page.
But what I did that I fixated in the victim's browser also with a specific path.
So it gets precedence.
I fixated the cookie that makes the server redirect them.
The next time they log in, it makes them at the server redirect them to the vulnerable page.
And it also puts the payload in the hash of the page.
So now the whole attack flow, I'm going to go through it from the beginning because it's hard to keep it all in mind.
The victim is in there, is peacefully using the application with their, with their account.
Now they navigate to the malicious page.
The malicious page actually in an iframe.
I didn't even have to do a window that open or anything.
Logs them into the attacker's account.
Now it redirects them to the vulnerable page where I, where they get X assessed.
That vulnerable page logs them out of the attacker's account by clearing all of the cookies with the cookie jar overflow.
And then it fixates the attacker's session for this specific vulnerable page.
And it also fixates the redirect cookie.
And then the page just redirects the victim to example.com or anything.
Now the victim forgets that the attack even happened after like a few days or something.
I made sure that the cookies would last up to like five years or something.
In case the victim wants to like go on vacation in the meantime or something.
Um, I, the next time the victim tries to use the application, they don't have any session cookies.
And this is actually the reason why I made sure to clear all the cookies.
So they won't like be logged into an attacker's account all of a sudden.
Right, right.
So now they get redirected to the login page and then they log into their account.
But now instead of getting redirected back to where they came from, the cookie that we have set takes precedence.
And the server actually tells them, um, that they should now be redirected after logging in to the vulnerable page with a, um, a payload in the URL.
So now they get redirected back to the vulnerable page and that page specifically in that page, they are logged in as the attacker.
Because in that page, we have fixated the cookie.
So for that specific page and that specific page only, the cookie that would take precedence is the attacker's session cookie.
So now the situation that we have, we have a little bubble, the vulnerable page where the victim is logged into the attacker's account and can be logged in.
And now I can fully exploit the cause misconfiguration and, um, interact with the APIs as the victim.
That's it.
Matan, that is disgusting.
That is an amazing vulnerability, dude.
Holy crap.
That's all, that's a, that's like a brand new way.
So, okay, hold up, hold up for a second.
They gave me like a 4k bonus, which was really good.
I imagine they would.
Um, so that's like a whole new way to exploit, uh, I found that all in like a few days.
Oh my gosh.
Or self excess.
Okay.
So, so the con you need a couple of gadgets.
You need the ability to redirect somebody after they log in.
With the cookies.
Yeah.
And then that's it.
And, and, and a way to log in CSRF, a way to log in CSRF, but that you already have to, have to exploit the self excess.
Wow dude.
So yeah, that's, that's really.
Okay.
Let me, let me just repeat it back to you one more time so I can make sure I got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you got, you got the, um, the login CSRF to self excess.
You use the self excess to clear all the cookies and set a, um, a redirect cookie.
Right.
That has the payload.
Yeah.
So you, the user then goes to log in with their browser primed for this whole thing.
It automatically redirects them.
Oh no, no.
You fixate the attacker session also with the path, with the path variable that takes a precedent.
And then when they go to log in, they get redirected to that page because of the redirect cookie on that page.
They are only that page.
They are logged in as the attacker because of the path.
Yeah.
Now you have just regular XSS.
And now you just have regular XSS.
Holy crap, dude.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
I mean, that gadget is super common.
You see all the time, like putting a path or even like some session code or something in the redirect cookie.
So the server knows where to redirect you.
Or even like a local storage, um, variable, uh, oftentimes.
Yeah.
Local storage is also something that you, as the attacker, but only if it's like same origin, but anyways, as the attacker, you could like set, like set and forget basically.
Or if you can find a gadget to inject it into, um, the local storage situation, that'd be really cool too.
Wow, dude.
That's a, that's an amazing technique.
I'm really glad you shared that.
That is a very high value share.
Um, that man.
I'm not sure I'm glad I shared that.
Yeah.
The path attribute, man, on cookies is so powerful.
That add is clutch.
And also the domain, the fact that you could set like cookies for domains that you shouldn't have access to.
Yeah.
Super, super powerful.
Um, wow, dude.
Yeah, you're, you're absolutely right.
We are not going to get through anything in this doc today.
Um, okay.
So we're gonna, we're gonna move all of the, um, we're gonna move all of the browser extension hacking stuff to a different day, I think.
And we're just gonna focus on for this episode.
We're gonna focus on, um, the rest of your reports that you've got here.
And then maybe we'll do some brainstorming about.
Yeah.
There's some very interesting stuff there.
Okay.
So that was sick.
Uh, what, what other ones you got, man, like keep on, give me, give me another one.
Do it again.
Yeah.
So I'm already running out of breath, but yeah.
Um, do you want to do this one or maybe?
Yeah, do that one.
That one's great.
Um, yeah, it's not simple, but we can do it.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
So what I had there, um, this is a bug that sort of combines, um, a lot with, um, cash deception, which is something that you don't really see together very often.
This was actually in a life hacking event.
So it was very fun to find.
And I didn't actually get a show until for that one.
I got a show until for a more boring bug.
Um, what happened there, there was a, a normal flow that let you, um, in the redirect URI, you could put it checked whether the redirect UI had a certain prefix, but, um, which is like the domain that they, um, trust.
Trust and then a specific path where they expect the callback to happen, but it only checks if it starts with that prefix and you could put like, um, path traversal payloads in the rest of the redirect URI.
So then what I had is like the ability to, um, um, in the domain where the, um, callback URL should be like, make the code land in every page on that domain, whatever path I wanted.
And then I noticed that domain, if you hit the route, like, um, URL, like just slash, it would redirect you to some, um, legitimate domain, like to some domain that had some UI and stuff.
This domain was like more of an internal API.
Um, so it would redirect you to that, um, to the main page.
And it would, it had some cash in front of it.
And I noticed that if I kept hitting that URL, I would get cache sheets.
So if I went to like slash and I sent the request, the first request would be like a miss.
And then if I kept sending them, I would be at hits.
And then I tried like going to slash a equals B and I send it and I keep getting hits after I send it.
And then what I realized that was actually very interesting is that the cache in the cache key, the, um, URL parameters weren't actually included.
So what happened is if I like went to slash a equals B and then I hit it once.
I hit it once and then I change it to like a equals C or even just remove the parameters completely.
I would get the same response.
And that response was a redirect to https legitimate domain.com slash a equals B.
Oh my gosh.
So now what I could do and what I actually did.
Um, I, I just made the victim navigate to the, um, to the OWASP flow URL with the redirect URI of, um, as legitimate path slash callback.
And then, uh, a lot of like path traversal sequences.
And then what happened is the victim navigated to that URL got redirected to, um, internal API domain slash, and then all of the parameters.
And then if right after he got the redirect response, I would from the same like region or whatever, I would send a request to just internal API path slash.
I would get the cached response that included the redirect and included the actual URL parameters.
Now I could just lick the code and the ATO them.
Dude, that is such an uncommon situation.
I've never seen a scenario where the cache key doesn't include the query parameter, but the response contains the query parameter that you put in the, like what?
Like what, that's so weird.
The cache should always include the, uh, search.
Uh, if you were to put like a cache buster on some specific, um, end point, you would put it in like the location search, like the search parameters.
I have no idea why the cache didn't include that, but.
So what you would do is you'd craft a scenario where it would launch an OAuth flow, hit the path traversal, hit this internal, or this like, you know, API domain where it has the weird caching.
And then, um, maybe hit a path that's like a unique ID or something like that.
And then, um, and then have the user's authorization code or whatever attached to that.
And then you, as the attacker would, uh, hit that end point afterwards and grab the code.
Just lick it.
And log in.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I mean, the backless is called cache deception, but I didn't have to do any deception in this case.
You just catched it for me.
Hey man, would you mind caching this?
Don't, don't include the query parameters.
Just, just how it is.
That's great, man.
That's so funny.
Wow, dude.
Um, I think this is a really good example of how you use chains really effectively, right?
Is because you, you're, you're noticing all of these little niche, um, caveats in these various primitives that you have across the scope.
And then you say, okay, you know, this primitive allows me to leak queer, queer parameters.
And then you find a way to, to, um, you know, land those query parameters on the, actually.
So let me ask you this.
Did which one of those did you find first?
Did you find the path traversal or the query parameter of caching?
I found the, um, the path traversal first.
Mm-hmm.
And then I tried to look for, um, ways to leak it from the, that, uh, domain.
Okay.
And that domain, it didn't have any functionality, like except, uh, or barely any functionality except that callback URL.
But yeah, and sometimes the functionality that you forget even exists like a cache on the redirect.
Yeah.
Any, any functionality except for this over eager cache.
Like I can cache that.
I can cache that for you.
That's hilarious.
Um, wow, dude.
Okay.
Very cool.
And I'm wondering, I'm wondering, did you, did you find this path traversal and then end up on this domain?
And then did you search, search, search until you found this primitive to allow you to leak the, the query parameters?
Or did you like move on to other things and that sort of thing?
I kind of just stumbled upon it pretty quickly, which was, was like pretty lucky.
And I, I never like run, um, I didn't run like any cache deception tools or I don't even know if those tools exist, but like,
I didn't run any tools on it.
I was just trying to check if there was any weird behavior there.
And I stumbled upon it pretty quickly because it was like, other than the, um, callback URL, it was the only other, um, URL I found that actually did something.
Wow, dude.
That's, that's nuts.
What a, what a crazy one.
Um, let's, let's move from there.
Let's go to this, um, six, seven, three, uh, one.
Cause then we can talk a little bit about.
Yeah.
I'm glad you skipped the, I'm glad you skipped the other one because that one is complicated.
Well, I'll mark that one for next time.
I'm not going to let you get off the hook without that.
Yeah, it is.
Um, it was just disclosed.
It's a bug on GitLab that has to do with, um, VS code.
I'm gonna try to make it sound as boring as possible.
So you don't, um, so you don't, uh, get sorry that we missed it, but, um, it has been disclosed on, um, GitLab now.
So if you have to check it out as soon as possible, you can do that.
Okay.
And then which, uh, there's two report numbers, which, what are the, which report number is it?
Um, and the one that got disclosed is the one that I wrote the CV for.
Okay.
Gotcha.
But the report isn't actually disclosed on like a one.
I asked them to disclose it, but they didn't do it yet.
Okay.
Um, but you can just, um, the web VS code XSS is a link.
I linked it to the, um, GitLab issue.
So you can put it in the description or something.
We'll put that in the notes.
Uh, the one that the bug explanation that we're skipping so that, um, so that you can go and do that.
All right.
Tell me about this, uh, this, so this is exactly what we were talking about earlier, actually, with DomLogger plus plus hooking the URL search params prototype dot get.
Right.
Yeah.
So it was an issue in like a big company, which tells you like the, the mistakes that some companies can make.
Um, it was, and, uh, I'm actually surprised that nobody else found it, but I was just looking through some, and it wasn't even a very weird, um, endpoint.
It was like an endpoint that gets visited all the time.
Mm-hmm.
Like one of the main endpoints of the main app.
And I just looked through the DomLogger, um, logs and I hooked like the exact same thing we talked about, like the URL search params prototype get and has.
Um, just to see which parameters they're trying to see.
And there was just a parameter named dev.
So of course I tried to look into that.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
And what that parameter was doing.
It accepted a URL to some JSON config file.
That config file.
Your heart is beating fast at this point.
When you see it like loads of JSON config file, you're like, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah.
And that config file had the property of a JS file.
And that JS file was loaded, not in the same origin in like some sandbox origin in, but in a worker.
And then they communicated with that worker and stuff.
And I managed to get some target specific impact out of that communication.
Very cool.
So, but yeah, that was interesting.
And it was like a free bug.
Yeah, dude.
I can't believe I can see here where you found that in the doc.
Um, we won't disclose it, but that's, that's crazy because that's gotta be one of the most assessed pieces of, of code like out there.
Um, so wow, that, that, that really just speaks to the power as well of Dom logger plus plus and how little introspection, um, the majority of, of hackers have into what's happening in their browser.
And I think that's one of the things that I really want to work with the community to change.
Yeah.
Because dude, Kevin is carrying us all on this, on this front.
And because just so much stuff happens, like so much stuff and you couldn't go through all of that manually if you wanted to.
Right.
And like it changes all the time and stuff.
You couldn't go through that manually.
Yeah.
So it's so important then to have a, a built up.
I mean, this is literally an essential tool, I think.
And the masterclass that we did at, at, in the pod and the critical thinkers channel, it totally changed my perspective on how to use Dom logger plus plus.
Yeah.
And I, I went that same day, even though I was in the middle of a live hacking event and I learned some config files for it because it's, it's that impactful.
And what I'd really like to see happen in the long term in this sort of, um, client side arena is to have a tool that's similar to like Kaido or Burp, right?
Something, a proxy of sorts that allows us to see what's happening at essential areas of our browser for as far as security assessment goes.
Yeah.
And I think that would require like, at a certain point you start to run into limitations of the browser.
Kevin already managed to do that.
Yeah.
With his extension.
Um, I think that would require like a fork of Chrome or whatever, which can be hard to maintain.
Yeah.
Super hard.
It might be, it might be an enterprise grade product to be perfectly honest.
And I would pay for it gladly, you know?
Um, and so I, I, I think that there's definitely some, some, and you know, uh, Dom Invader does, does this to some degree.
Um, but I think, I think there's, I'd much rather have something that just lets me know what's going on rather than alerts on things.
Yeah.
And that's like more independent.
Like, I don't like it when tools are too.
Like monolithic.
Yeah.
Locked into their environment.
So having, yeah.
Having to open up a bell to open the browser to do client side testing.
And you can like, you can't turn on and off the proxy for that browser and the bell browser that has the, um, what's it called?
The Dom Invader.
Yeah.
Built into it.
I agree.
So I think we need an outside product and I, it would, it would be really cool if Google would just give us like a, uh, you know, a setting or something like that.
A flag.
Yeah.
Where we could go in and just, cause we were, we were discussing with Kevin in the masterclass.
Um, you know, there's not really a way for us to overwrite document location.href and, and, and, and, you know, proxy that.
Yeah.
Um, so I, I think, uh, a feature flag for that would be really, really helpful and, and allow, um, you know, extensions or whatever to, to hook into that and, and gain introspection there.
Um, so what I wanted to do with this last little segment that we'll do here is just kind of discuss what kind of things we would want to see in that, that client side heads up display.
I'm, I'm sort of in picture or in picturing, I'm kind of envisioning a, uh, that's not a word, uh, uh, uh, envisioning a, you know, a separate application that's linked into the browser via an extension.
And that's giving us introspection into everything that's going on in the page.
And you can sort of do this with dev tools already, but I think it'd be helpful to have it be an external.
But even dev tools is limited.
Yeah.
Like I think dev tools needs also needs a chromium fork.
Seriously.
Yeah.
Sometimes like, especially like I mentioned earlier in the network tab, it does like requests that just tells you like, I can't find that.
Like when you're trying to look at the responses, it tells like, it says, it says like, I can't find the response to that request.
Like why?
Like, I see it here.
Like what, where did it go?
Did you lose it?
Like, um, yeah.
So it's the, that's definitely a tricky part there.
Um, so here's here.
And I actually, I really liked that section.
I think it's like very creative.
Yeah.
So it's actually, it would be very useful to see.
Let's, let's kind of talk about what we'd like to see.
There are a couple of things that came to mind of course is going to be changes in registered hand, uh, handlers.
So like, for example, if, if a often run into a scenario and this is actually, um, the sort of scenarios where I'm finding a lot of post message vulnerabilities nowadays, as it's becoming a little bit more mainstream.
Well, it's like temporary.
It's, it's dynamically generated.
Uh, you know, and you've got either a user clicks on something and then it opens up a post message listener, or it's a temporal post message listener that just gets registered for a short period of time and then gets closed.
Um, yeah.
And there are, there are some weird conditions sometimes like, um, only if I'm, if the window has a parent or only if, yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
And so those sorts of thing, you know, any registration of post message listeners or new hash event, uh, hash change events is also really interesting.
Um, because those are ways that you can kind of get weasel your way in there.
Um, uh, what other handlers do we have?
That kind of ties into, um, what I call like universal sources, which is something you have like in client side hacking.
It's like sources of input that exists that like the browser level and exist for every, um, target, almost every target, unless they're using cross origin opener policy.
Right.
Unfortunately.
Yeah.
But anyways, yeah.
So all of those are like essential to see, um, in any type of client side, it's all displays heads up display.
Yeah.
So like a hash change event or a post message event, or even, and this sort of references, um, some research done by, um, space raccoon and a paste event.
Um, that might require some more exotic user interaction.
Um, but you could make a user like paste attacker controlled input somewhere or maybe, and I didn't try to the, in the doc, but it's also a clip applicable.
Um, a drop event, like for the drag drop event.
Yeah.
You could like, um, make user drag something and then open up a new window and make them drop it there.
I think that's really easy to actually have happen to be perfectly honest, you know?
Yeah.
And maybe there's a specific set of people that you couldn't target, you know, but like, there's so many browser games where it's like, you know, drag this thing or like, do you know?
And, and I think it's really, I think it's likely that you could get someone to do that.
It's all about like the way you present it.
Um, there are like a lot of cases, like maybe upload the file or I don't know.
I'm sure you could somehow convince me to drag and drop something.
Yeah.
It should be pretty simple.
Um, that it wonder, and it does make me wonder then like, when does it cross the line of like, if you have a compliant user,
then you can just sort of make them enter their creds, you know, into your site.
Yeah.
Right.
That's what I don't like about, um, CVSS.
Yeah.
One of the things I don't like, there are many, but like, um, the fact that user interaction is binary.
Like for me as a hacker, once I get like, um, once I, my exploit needs a victim to navigate to my, uh, site and I already have like user interaction required,
I've already paid that cost.
Yeah.
I can just like go crazy with it.
Like click here five times, like this and pop it here.
Like, yeah.
Stand up, do a dance, you know, like, do the hookah hookah.
Open up your webcam and give me permission.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I think record a pod with the victim.
Record a pod with the victim.
That's hilarious.
Dude.
If, uh, if Riverside had a program that would definitely be like a good one.
It's like, you have to get the victim on your podcast.
And then also that's the reason I'm here.
Yeah, man.
Just, just a couple more minutes.
My, my exploit takes two hours.
So we're going to have to.
Yeah.
Your exploit was leaking, um, excess leaks.
Leaking all your sensitive techniques character by character.
Um, no, that's good.
I'm already leaking it.
Um, in my discord chat with you.
Right.
Exactly.
Um, all right.
So yeah, the other thing obviously is like post message conversations.
That one's, that one's pretty great.
We had that with, um, yeah, that one's essential.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
You need to have that.
And I think that would be, it would be cool to have a nice user interface for that too.
And to be honest, I would totally pay for this product.
Like if this was, you know, I would pay $50, a hundred.
I mean, I don't pay for much, but I would pay $50 a month for a product that really nailed this.
Yeah.
Definitely.
And, and you know, something that makes post message conversations really easy to follow and easy to track.
Um, uh, new frames that are B are popping up on the page.
Right.
That one I actually really liked because I personally, I personally have found myself like catch myself missing that a lot of the time.
Um, the way I like check which frames are available.
It's just like after the page is finished loading, I just go through the elements and see which I frames there are.
But in many cases, an I frame just like pops up and, um, it gets removed and that sort of stuff.
And then I just noticed like in the post message tracker, which sort of like logs, um, post message listeners and keeps them logged even after you like close them or remove them.
I noticed like some frames that I didn't even see in the page.
Yeah.
And that is something that the person I am currently missing all the time on show.
So yeah, I'm sure there's ephemeral bugs like that, especially in reauthorization flows when you get to a page, you know, it's very common for them to like, let me just pop up in this I frame and do some like OAuth magic in here to like get my session token back out and then delete the I frame.
So I think that that could be pretty common.
And I think also a great way to see the frames is just sources.
And then on the left hand side, you know, where in the page tab, um, you know, you have like all the, it logs also the frames that are removed.
It doesn't log the ones that are removed, but it does allow you to show the ones.
So if you have that open, when you navigate to the page, you'll see it sort of like, like we just said, in the application tab.
Yeah.
Oh, in the application, will it, will it do it in the application tab too?
Oh yeah, it will.
But it, that doesn't, that doesn't include.
It doesn't, that doesn't include ones that were ephemerally.
Mm.
I'm talking about in the sources tab.
Dude.
So click, click dev tools, go to sources.
And then you see on the left hand side where it says top.
Yeah.
So it will show the other frames over there as well.
If you have an iPhone.
And even, even ones that were like popped up and removed.
No, not that.
Yeah.
So just, just, just normal ones.
Uh, just ones that are currently in the page.
Yeah.
So I just like control F for iframe.
That'll do it too.
So new frames.
Um, what do you think about local storage slash session storage, read and writes?
Yeah.
It's more niche.
It's pretty rare to have, um, gadgets that let you control it.
Mm.
A bit lesser to have gadgets that let you control some part of it.
Um, I actually have one.
I can show it to you in, uh, in the, um, uh, backbone in the LHE scope.
Yeah.
Um, a certain like, um, local storage, uh, pollution.
Uh, yeah.
Like a specific, um, setting, a specific key that holds like a JSON object with some settings.
Um, there's a listener that lets you set it.
Um, but I have been actually, it's pretty tough to see like where they're using it.
So maybe this could also be implemented with, uh, maybe a dom logger config, but it would
be very noisy, like logging, um, which is also might be a problem with like a heads up display
like that, that local storage gets used, gets used all the time with all sorts of different
keys and it's gonna be, um, pretty noisy, but if you grip for like a certain key, it will be fine.
Yeah.
And I, I think also CSPT like tracker, the, the, the tool that we have in the critical thinkers
just scored, um, you know, what that does is it looks at the, you know, the, the path,
the query parameters, the hash or whatever, and then it traces those values into fetch
requests or exit HR requests that are, you know, I frames that are happening, uh, as sub resources.
And I think something similar could be implemented here.
Um, unfortunately there are some, some frameworks that just literally put the current page in
a local storage, you know, uh, cell or whatever.
So that would be super noisy, but like being able to track the current page, you know,
like being able to trace values from like, okay, you know, this was in the hash and now it's in the
local storage.
Yeah.
That should be pretty high signal, right?
From the hash.
I think actually.
Yeah.
I think actually the CSPT extension, um, is maybe like one, one specific use case of that, you know, technique.
Mm-hmm.
And once you have it built out, like you have it in your, um, CSPT extension, I think it's
gonna be very valuable to like generalize it a bit and like, um, iframe source setters or like location
things, like all of the, basically the universal things because browsers, so they have like the universal sources,
which is what we talked about, like location search, um, location in general and post messages and all of that good stuff that we want to have visibility into.
But they also have like, um, um, global sinks.
So if you already have the ability to trace some of the sources, maybe not all of them.
Um, because something like post messages will be, will be very hard to trace.
But if you have it built out, like you have it with the extension, I think it's gonna be very interesting to start adding some.
Yeah.
It gets a little bit less high signal though.
When we do that, that's the, that's the really tricky part for this heads up display.
If someone were to take on this project, the biggest challenge would be figuring out what we do.
And then also making sure that your users can customize the extension, uh, in the app thoroughly.
So it doesn't end up like belt issues.
Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
I didn't, you said it, not me, you know, like, exactly.
Um, yeah, but yeah.
This page doesn't have a secure, whatever.
But you know, it's interesting though, because, um, James had a point, James Kettle had a point when, when we were in the app.
When we were discussing something recently about the new, uh, character, um, character set.
Char set?
Yeah. The char set, uh, uh, thing research that came out recently.
Yeah. I did see that logged in the, um, in the belt issues.
Yeah. What was that? Oh yeah.
Sonar, Sonar research came out with that, that, um, that research on essentially being able to dynamically change the, the character set and convert backslashes into Yen symbols.
Um, amazing, but not as common as you would think it would is because almost all pages are actually specifying the character set that's being used.
Um, but James, uh, when we were discussing it, James kind of popped in and said, Hey, um, you know, burp has been alerting on the fact that there is not a specified character set, uh, by default for like 10 years.
And I was like, okay, well that's really interesting. And that is a cool.
But it got lost, it got lost in all of the other, um, yeah.
Logged issues.
But it makes you wonder, you know, how many of these little issues like can be chained together and can be furthered a little bit more.
And, and apply.
Yeah. I mean, I'm sure, I'm sure it's not as easy as I imagine it. And I'm sure if I was a developer of burp, I would have done a worse job.
Yeah.
And because it's a, it's a very hard like issue. And I mean, um, I don't judge them for like it being a bit noisy.
And I mean, for what it's worth, they did, they do have some feature that let you like sort by, they have, um, severity.
For every issue. And they also have confidence, which I really like. I think it's good design. So, yeah.
Yeah. So you might have like, um, I don't know, the scanner thinks that there's an SQL line in there, which you would like be very interested in that, in that, but, um, it has different levels of like how confident it is.
Mm-hmm .
So if it only saw like an error message that looks similar, or I don't know how it does it, but like, um, then you might have it be like a critical issue, but, um, have it, uh, be like low confidence, which is a good design.
Yeah. I, I totally agree. I really, I really liked that design, um, from burp.
All right. So yeah. And I, I think just going back to the conversation of like, this kind of needs its own Chrome fork.
Um, I really do think that if the, if someone was to build this, it would be, there needs to be some way to grab introspection into, uh, you know, window location.href or whatever.
Um, because I, I think that would be extremely valuable and would further, further the product.
Um, and sort of the reason for that is we really just want to know what inputs we have to a specific client side path.
Right. And, you know, hooking URL search params is great, but URL search params hasn't really good.
But URL search params hasn't been around for forever.
Um, so we really need, uh, you know, access to window location.href custom parsing, um, which should be able to be done.
Uh, if we can override, if you can apply, you know, the proxy to that actual attribute, um, which you can't by defaulting Chromium.
So I don't know, maybe we need to hit up the guys at Google and be like, Hey, look, can you just make this happen, please?
Why does it be huge?
So I'm currently, um, you sort of reminded me of this with the, um, encoding differentials research from Sonar.
Um, I saw there was one Wikipedia article, which I'm currently trying to find.
Uh, we're gonna add it to the, uh, description later, but, um, that has sort of a list.
I don't think it's a comprehensive list.
There weren't a lot of, um, different charts in there, but it's just a list of a few different charts and the escape, um, sequence that you can use to, um, change into those charts.
And for my testing, um, all of the ones that I've tested from the article of world.
So it's definitely because the, um, the article only lists a few and like maybe two, but, um, the research can be generalized to a few more charts if you need them for some reason.
Dude, that's pretty sick.
Like if, if the certain application supports it or something like that, that's pretty rad.
Um, all right, dude, I just realized that I miscalculated, uh, the time that I needed to end this podcast at, and I am late to the airport.
So I've got to go.
Um, yeah.
Yeah.
I think we, we will come back to all of this.
Uh, I think we'll come back to this one next time too.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna highlight this one for next time.
Um, and Richard, if you can move this to a doc, that would be great.
I'm just, I love, I love critical thinking podcast, man.
I'm just like talking to my, uh, to my editor, like right on the pod live.
To your minions.
Yeah.
Well, Matan dude, thanks so much for coming on, man.
It's been a blast.
I could talk to you for hours.
Yeah, definitely.
All right, man.
Um, I will see you in Vegas in a couple of weeks, right?
Yeah.
Thanks so much for inviting me on the pod.
It's been really fun.
Of course, man.
It's always a blast.
All right.
Talk to you soon.
Peace brother.
See ya.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctvb.show slash discord.
Join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us.
We'll see you there.
Bye.